Ernest you're a good man aren't
you yes you're right I suppose
so you suppose so are you aren't you I
am sir I am you love your wife and
children yes sir I do served your
country and infantry and and I don't
think this is how your life was meant to
turn out
now
it seems to me your family back
home they're more of a blessing to you
than your
uncle King Bill
hail you and I both know he presents
himself as a very righteous
man and that's just not who he
is
he's done nothing for you
son
except make you do bad things and take
advantage of you because of
your
disposition so what do you say we start
over I
yeah I want to get home to see my
wife you
will he tell me what I got to
do you know who killed Henry
Rome